let's learn how to create decades-long
tradition for high school students
looking to test their knowledge and
competition one member of our CBS
mornings family knows it very well
looking for the foreign
[Music]
quiz Bowlers have faced the pressure of
the buzzer and showed off their
knowledge in front of the cameras but as
Scott shows us times have changed and
now the quiz Bowl programs themselves
are facing pressure just to survive
ghost God
this is Varsity quiz
welcome to whisk with everyone
the lights the noise the pressure round
one forget about football or basketball
welcome to the ultimate High School
adrenaline sport
Hannah one of the current Superstars is
Hannah bunting of Kecoughtan High School
in Hampton Virginia
swims and plays field hockey but says
this is what really makes her sweat
Hannah noon's first law of motion that
is correct is it nerve-wracking it's
very nerve-wracking especially leading
up to it all the anticipation which
weighs more cream or skim milk skim milk
since the 1960s thousands of student
quiz Bowlers have faced tests of
knowledge about anything and everything
history algebra chemistry baseball
Marvel movies trivia winner of three
World Cups what soccer hero from uh
ballet ballet is correct perhaps no
surprise many alumni of these shows have
gone on to prominent careers you were
The Underdogs we were The Underdogs no
one thought we'd win as a student at
James Madison High School in Brooklyn
New York Senator Chuck Schumer and his
team battled other schools on its
academic in the 1960s I was always a
little nervous before going on the show
but the minute I sat in that chair I was
rolling all right all right walking
through his old school nice what do you
teach physics Schumer attributes some of
his success to that early moment beneath
the bright lights did you feel like you
carried anything from that experience
into what was has to be one of the
tougher jobs in America the one you have
now confidence confidence spell
acquittal
now it's the quiz shows themselves being
put to the test between budget concerns
and other shifting priorities CBS News
found at least a half dozen of these
shows have been canceled in recent years
and one organization says the number of
high schools participating in their
competitions has decreased by about 250
over the past five years we were walking
on a knife's edge there for a while
Scott Washington D.C is home to the
world's longest running TV quiz show
according to the Guinness Book of World
Records we'll begin with team one but it
nearly went extinct two years ago after
their longtime sponsor pulled its money
says host Hillary Howard we were forced
to find new sponsors which is not an
easy task it's not an inexpensive show
to put on DC's its academics survived
largely thanks to a philanthropist who
has charitably kept the cameras rolling
and the buzzers blaring it's important
to be in a studio you know that's what
it's all about we're saying you're
special and they can feel it
love it behind the scenes you learn
winning isn't just about what you know
name this famous groundhog that comes
out each year but about when
Punxsutawney Phil correct timing is
everything once you buzz in the question
stops Buzz too soon
you could miss a key detail Buzz too
late what is the capital of South Dakota
Hannah here correct and players like
Hannah beat you to the punch good luck
today guys you can see the nerves before
the matches if you just have a camera
behind them you'll just see shaking legs
the whole time they're very good at
staying composed the way stuff but their
towels are always on their feet in 1741
the first Hannah says it is a team sport
players split up Specialties and train
together you're answering the questions
individually but you're studying
together and you're building up points
together and there's momentum one
correct answer lifts the confidence
sliding officer Hannah
Hancock that's correct John Hancock
players with encyclopedic brains just
never seem to forget do you remember the
question you won on yes I never forgot
it what was it what molecule caused the
pigment in white paint to be white and
the answer was titanium dioxide who
would have known
that's great still amazing student you
saw Hannah bunting is going to go to
Virginia Commonwealth University in the
fall full tuition scholarships she'll go
to med school after that she says and
for this student who knows to buzz in
real quick and answer when she has the
answer
waited a while had other schools offer
and took her time and made the right
decision for her I like watching you
that was my favorite part of the story
15 years old were you nervous when
you're sitting up there doing that and
you gave this big smile no there it is
[Laughter]
but Scott were you nervous Rocky smile
no no that's the Difference Maker I
wasn't the smartest I wasn't the most
knowledgeable but I was least
intimidated by the cameras and the
lights and I figured well maybe we
should do this for a living and you did
too today the smartest and the most
knowledgeable and there you are Scott
McFarland on CBS that was great that was
great bravo bravo to you thank you